hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich mache heute eine leckere
beilage und zwar gibt es einen
griechischen beilagen reis und tomaten
reiße ich hab nämlich heute schon
vorbereitet hier dieses wichtig wie die
werde ich gleich anbraten ich hab sie
mir schon gerichtet und dieses rezept
bekommt die auch in einem anderen video
und in diesem ritter in diesem video
möchte ich euch jetzt dass tomaten reis
rezept zeigen und zeigt euch einfach mal
ganz christi zutaten
ich brauche drei esslöffel olivenöl eine
knoblauchzehe eine zwiebel eine prise
salz einer prise zucker
ich habe ich 250 gramm langkornreis und
den habe ich schon unter heißem wasser
gewaschen und abtropfen lassen
dann 400 gramm tomaten aus der dose salz
und pfeffer etwas minze und 600
milliliter wasser und zwar benutze ich
bei diesem rezept tomaten aus der dose
weil ihr dann einfach jahreszeitlich
unabhängig seit ihr könnt den reis zu
jeder jahreszeit zu bereiten und die
tomaten sind einfach immer aromatisch
also normalerweise kann man im sommer
zum beispiel so richtig tolle
aromatische tomaten nehmen
aber im winter und so weit würde ich
halt eher auf die tomaten stücke
zurückgreifen
und es ist jetzt übrigens auch so ein
rezept das habe ich von unseren
griechischen freund bekommen und zeigt
euch also wenn ihr das gezeigt hat also
zuerst braucht ihr jetzt die zwiebel und
knoblauchzehe und die werden fein
gewürfelt
wir schauen der großen topf gerichtet da
kommen jetzt drei esslöffel olivenöl
rein und dann auch direkt die zwiebel
und knoblauch würfel und die werden
jetzt bei mit hoher hitze so classic
angebraten
jetzt kommt auch direkt der reis mit
dazu da wird es auch ein bisschen mit
gebraten und zwar wetter einfach die
stärke gefunden und der reis wird später
schön locker klebrig gebe es hier auch
direkt den zucker mit rein geradezu eine
prise und zwar nimmt es den tomaten die
säure weg und hebt auch den tomaten
geschmack investieren
jetzt kommen die tomaten mit rein und
dann spiele ich auch direkt ist dose mit
dem wasser aus und gibt es restliche
wasser mit rein jetzt einmal durchführen
damit nichts anklebt unten
jetzt könnte das direkt auch salzen und
pfeffern
und dann kommt noch ein teelöffel minze
mit rein getrocknete und jetzt muss erst
mal kurz aufkochen
der reis kocht jetzt kann ich die
temperatur unterstellen und den deckel
drauf setzen
dann kann er nämlich so etwa 15 minuten
durch gaben bis er die komplette
flüssigkeit aufgezogen hat und in der
zwischenzeit werde ich schon mal meine
bestecke hier in der pfanne anbraten
der reise sind fertig und ich habe ihn
jetzt eben nochmal abgeschmeckt bei mir
hat noch ein bisschen salz gefehlt und
ihr könnt entweder so pur servieren
finde ich aber ziemlich langweilig weil
im prinzip ist es nur ein tomaten reis
oder er serviert ihn ebenso etwas mit
dazu bei mir gibt es wie gesagt dazu
etwas bft kinocenter zicke gemacht und
gleich mache ich noch einen leckeren
bauernsalat und wenn ihr das rezept nach
machen wollt geht einfach auf meinen
blog of sales blog.de ich würde mich
freuen wenn ihr dieses gericht nach
kocht und mir dann ein foto auf facebook
oder twitter verschickt also viel spaß
beim nachkochen und bis zum nächsten mal